it is now almost two months since the
people of this country began to put up
with restrictions on their freedom your
freedom of a kind that we have never
seen before in peace or war and you have
shown the good sense to support those
rules overwhelmingly you've put up with
all the hardships of that program of
social distancing because you understand
that as things that and as the
experience of every other country has
shown it's the only way to defeat the
coronavirus the most vicious threat this
country has faced in my lifetime and
though the death toll has been tragic
and the suffering immense and though we
grieve for all those we have lost it is
a fact that by adopting those measures
we prevented this country from being
engulfed by what could have been a
catastrophe in which the reasonable
worst-case scenario was half a million
fatalities and it's thanks to your
effort and sacrifice in stopping the
spread of this disease that the death
rate is coming down and hospital
admissions are coming down and thanks to
you we've protected our NHS and saved
many thousands of lives and so I know
you know that it would be madness now to
throw away that achievement by allowing
a second spike we must stay alert we
must continue to control the virus and
save lives and yet we must also
recognize that this campaign against the
virus has come at colossal cost to our
way of life we can see it all around us
in the shuttered shops and abandoned
businesses and darkened pubs and
restaurants and there are millions of
people who are both fearful of this
terrible disease and at the same time
also fifth of what this long period of
enforced inactivity will do to their
livelihoods and their mental and
physical well-being to their futures and
the futures of their children so I want
to provide tonight for you
the shape of a plan to address both
fears both to beat the virus and provide
the first sketch of a roadmap for
reopening society a sense of the way
ahead and when and how and on what basis
we will take the decisions to proceed
I'll be sending out more details in
Parliament tomorrow and taking questions
from the public in the evening I've
consulted across the political spectrum
across all four nations of the UK and
though different parts of the country
are experiencing the pandemic at
different rates and though it's right to
be flexible in our response I believe
that as Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom Scotland England Wales Northern
Ireland there is a strong resolve to
defeat this together
and today a general consensus on what we
could do and I stress could because
although we have a plan it is a
conditional plan and since our priority
is to protect the public and save lives
we cannot move forward unless we satisfy
the five tests we must protect our NHS
we must see sustained falls in the death
threat we must see sustained and
considerable falls in the rate of
infection we must sort out our
challenges in getting enough PPE to the
people who need it and yes
it's a global problem but we must fix it
and last we must make sure that any
measures we take do not force the
reproduction rate of the disease the are
back up over one so that we have the
kind of exponential growth we were
facing a few weeks ago and to chart our
progress and to avoid going back to
square one we're establishing a new Co
vide alert system run by a new joint
biosecurity Center and that co vid alert
level will be determined primarily by
our and the number of coronavirus cases
and in turn that kobe the alert level
will tell us how tough we have to be in
our social distancing measures the lower
the level the few of the measures the
higher the level the tougher and
stricter we will have to be there will
be five alert levels level one means the
disease is no longer present in the UK
and level five is the most critical the
kind of situation we could have had if
the NHS had been overwhelmed over the
period of the lockdown we've been in
level four and it's thanks to your
sacrifice were now in a position to
begin to move in steps to level three
and as we go everyone will have a role
to play in keeping the order by staying
alert and following the rules and to
keep pushing the number of infections
done there are two more things we must
do we must reverse rapidly the awful
epidemics in care homes and in the NHS
and though the numbers are coming down
sharply now there is plainly much more
to be done and if we're to control this
virus then we must have a world-beating
system the testing potential victims and
for tracing their contacts so that all
told we are testing literally hundreds
of thousands of people every day we've
made fast progress on testing but there
is so much more to do now and we can
when this began we hadn't seen this
disease before and we didn't fully
understand its effects with every day
we're getting more and more data we're
shining the light of science on this
invisible killer and we will pick it up
where it strikes because our new system
will be able in time
detect local flare-ups in your area as
well as giving us a national picture and
yet when I look at where we are tonight
we have the are below 1 between 0.5 and
point 9 but potentially only just below
1 and though we have made progress in
satisfying at least some of the
conditions I have given we have by no
means fulfilled all of them and so no
this is not the time simply to end the
lockdown this week instead we're taking
the first careful steps to modify our
measures and the first step is a change
of emphasis that we hope that people
will act on this week we said that you
should work from home if you can and
only go to work
if you must we now need to stress that
anyone who can't work from home for
instance those in construction or
manufacturing should be actively
encouraged to go to work and we want it
to be safe for you to get to work so you
should avoid public transport if at all
possible because we must and will
maintain social distancing and capacity
will therefore be limited so work from
home if you can but you should go to
work if you can't work from home and to
ensure you're safe at work we've been
working to establish new guidance for
employers to make workplaces couvade
secure and when you do go to work if
possible
do so by car or even better by walking
or bicycle but just as with workplaces
public transport operators will also be
following coded secure standards and
from this Wednesday we want to encourage
people to take more and even unlimited
amounts of outdoor exercise you can sit
in the Sun in your local park you can
drive to other destinations you can even
play sports
only with members of your own household
you must obey the rules on social
distancing and to enforce those rules we
will increase the fines for the small
minority who break them and so every day
with ever-increasing data we will be
monitoring the are and the number of new
infections and the progress we are
making and if we as a nation begin to
fulfill the conditions I have set out
then the next few weeks and months we
may be able to go further in step two
are the earliest by June the first after
half term we believe we may be in a
position to begin the phased reopening
of shops and to get primary pupils back
into schools in stages beginning with
reception year one and year six our
ambition is that secondary pupils facing
exams next year will get at least some
time with their teachers before the
holidays will shortly be setting out
detailed guidance on how to make it work
in schools and shops and on transport
and step three are the earliest by July
and subject to all these conditions and
further scientific advice if and only if
the numbers supported we will hope to
reopen at least some of the hospitality
industry and other public places
provided they're safe and enforce social
distancing throughout this period of the
next two months we will be driven not by
mere hope or economic necessity we're
going to be driven by the science the
data and public health and I must stress
again that all of this is conditional it
all depends on a series of big IFS it
depends on all of us the entire country
to follow the advice to observe social
distancing and to keep that are down and
to prevent reinfection from abroad I am
serving notice that it will soon be the
time with transmission signal
differently lower to impose quarantine
on people coming into this country by
air and it's because of your efforts to
get the are down and the number of
infections down here that this measure
will now be effective and of course
we'll be monitoring our progress locally
regionally and nationally and if there
are outbreaks if there are problems we
will not hesitate to put on the brakes
we've been through the initial peak but
it's coming down the mountain that is
often more dangerous we have a route and
we have a plan and everyone in
government has the all-consuming
pressure and challenge to save lives
restore livelihoods and gradually
restore the freedoms that we need but in
the end this is a plan that everyone
must make work and when I look at what
you've done already the patience and
common sense you show the fortitude of
the elderly who is isolation we all want
to end as fast as we can the incredible
bravery and hard work of our NHS staff
our care workers the devotion and
self-sacrifice of all those in every
walk of life who are helping us to beat
this disease police bus drivers train
drivers pharmacists supermarket workers
Road hauliers bin collectors cleaners
security guards postal workers our
teachers and a thousand more the
scientists who are working around the
clock to find a vaccine when I think of
the millions of everyday acts of
kindness and thoughtfulness that are
being performed across this country and
that have helped to get us through this
first phase I know that we can use this
plan to get us through the next and if
we can't do it by those dates and if the
alert level won't allow it
we will simply wait and go on until
we've got it right we will come back
from this devilish illness we will come
back to health and robust health and
though the UK will be changed by this
experience I believe we can be stronger
and better
than ever before more resilient more
innovative more economically dynamic but
also more generous and more sharing but
for now we must stay alert control the
virus and save lives thank you very much